la parole est à Monsieur C pour le
groupe les républicains oui madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'Éducation nationale j'y associe mes
collègues de tout bord qui sont
également attachés à l'apprentissage
intense et précoce de l'allemand en
particulier pierre Yv Leborgne président
du groupe d'amitié France- Allemagne
madame la ministre votre réforme du
collège aura pour conséquence de
reléguer l'apprentissage de l'allemand
au rang de la culture de l'orchidée
selon l'expression justement choisie par
l'ancienne ambassadrice d'Allemagne en
France c'est ainsi qu'en supprimant les
sections européennes et en posant de
nouvelles conditions pour accéder à un
semblant de classe bilang vous comptez
révolutionner l'apprentissage de
l'allemand tous les professionnels
compétents sur cette question non soumis
au dictate général imposé sont pourtant
unanimes un collège qui possède en 2015
une classe bilangue et une section
européenne offre aujourd'hui de la 6e à
la 3e un total hebdomadaire de 16 he de
cours d'
après la réforme ce même établissement n
proposera plus que 7h3 oui madame la
ministre que vous le vouliez ou non la
réalité des vrais chiffres ce que vous
balayez aveuglément d'un revers de la
main sera toujours présente pour vous
rappeler que vous faites fausse route et
ce ne sont ni les sorties opération
promotion et séduction effectué en
Lorine avec une délégation vouée à votre
cause ni même les tours de passe-p
politicien qui demain donneront à notre
jeunesse les connaissances linguistiques
nécessaires pour trouver un emploi
madame la ministre est-ce de cette façon
que vous souhaitez renforcer l'allemand
et transposer en France la de stratégie
qui permettra dans les 20 prochaines
années à la jeunesse soise de maîtriser
la langue française on savait la réforme
baclé l'apprentissage de l'allemand le
montre de façon manifeste face à ce
constat et prenant acte de votre volonté
de créer plus de postes de professeur
d'allemand madame la ministre dites-moi
que deviendront-ils donc à la rentrée
2016 sans élèves face à eux merci
Monsieur let la parole est à Madame Naj
Val belcassa ministre de
l'Éducation ah oui bon merci Madame la
présidentees mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député let passer
les débats éruptifs et pour le moins
confus du printemps dernier j'aurais pu
imaginer que vous preniez les 5 derniers
mois pour aller vous pencher réellement
sur ce que dit la réforme du collège
j'ai évité ce genre de question bon ça
n'a pas été fait donc je veux bien avec
toute la pédagogie qui me caractérise
vous redire à nouveau que s'il est bien
un reproche que l'on ne peut pas
adresser à cette réforme du collège
c'est de diminuer l'apprentissage des
langues vivantes puisque ce que prévoit
la réforme du collège par définition
c'est d'augmenter cet apprentissage les
élèves apprendront leur langue vivante
numéro 2 en classe de 5e et non plus en
classe de 4e ce qui signifie sur une
scolarité au collège
4 heur de plus d'enseignement des
langues vivantes 2 et donc de l'allemand
en particulier s'agissant d'ailleurs de
la langue vivante une cette fois-ci qui
s'apprend elle à l'école primaire je
vous rappelle que nous avons décidé qu'à
la rentrée prochaine au lieu d'attendre
le CE1 cette langue vivante une ça
prendrait elle dè le CP donc les élèves
si je résume gagnent un an
d'apprentissage de la LV1 un an
d'apprentissage de la LV2 expliquez-moi
comment il serait moins bien l'tique
aujourd'hui l'allemand maintenant
l'allemand je souhaite qu'il y ait
davantage d'élèves français qui prennent
l'allemand en langue vivante c'est la
raison pour laquelle je nous ai fixé des
objectif augmenter de 10 % le nombre
d'apprenants à l'école primaire en LV1
comme au collège en LV2 10 % pour ce
faire nous embauchons davantage de
professeurs d'Allemands nous allons
chercher des étudiants allemands nous
l'avons vu avec l'ambassadeur
d'Allemagne en France en Allemagne pour
les faire exercer comme assistant de
langue dans les écoles primaires
françaises dispositif que V vre majorité
avait supprimé avant que nous arrivions
au responsabilité donc monsieur le
député soyons sérieux une minute demain
c'est-à-dire à la rentrée 2016 vous
aurez beaucoup plus d'élèves qui
pratiqueront l'allemand en1 comm mer la
parole est à Madame